all right let's uh let's sit up
something about this situation Jenny
okay Mountain let's call it high because
you just take you know logicians and
let's call it two kilometers away like
it so suppose we have a target set up on
the top of the mountain okay that's a
target and we want to when we hit the
target and it's that kind of distance
away now what I'm gonna make this is a
question about varying the angle of
inclination okay so I mean this is
pretty typical but like if it's a tank
they don't they don't say like let's
fire it a little bit hard or really hard
how fast it fires is generally fixed
okay so let's call that outward velocity
let's say 200 meters per second but what
you can change quite easily is on where
where you actually are pointing as you
fire okay and we want to hit right on
the target and that's how far away it is
okay so let's have a few question to you
number one what angle should I fire okay
once you work out the angle what's going
to be the flat time how long is the
element attack how long's a shell going
to be in the air okay and lastly can we
work out impact speed and impact angle
okay very CSI trying to work out yeah
that's right if anything we could do
that
okay so we gotta go now remember I told
you that we always start with these two
equations through acceleration and then
we're going to integrate up as we go
okay so let's start with just the
horizontal I guess so begin by saying X
double dot equal to 0 okay so if I
integrate once I'm going to get X star
okay so if you need to green into your
what do you get you get a constant now
if you've had a look at some of the
examples which most of you not oh you
can see I'm gonna enter it many times so
I'm gonna have many different constants
okay so I better call it something
better than say I'll call it Z one
that's much that's a vast improvement
isn't it now exercise is equal to you
want I've got to work out where this
constant is before it go any further so
how do that okay so I'm going to need to
know when T equals zero I'm gonna need
to know a few things
yeah so for instance I should probably
set a location for this now what do you
think would be a nice definition for the
tank
I always work for eternity like say the
origin no North Korea okay great okay
we're starting at the origin in North
Korea now we also need to know about
where where it's going right because I'm
after velocity right so I need some kind
of initial collision condition that's
connected to that right so if I want X
dot I'm gonna need to take pass I need
to take this information and we're gonna
have to resolve the velocities right
yeah so how am I gonna do this how do I
resolve velocities again so I can draw a
my triangle right he's firing upwards
you guys might have had a looking
questions where you just fire
horizontally something like that now I
know what V is that's 200 okay but I
don't know what the angle is right in
fact that's that's what I'm trying to
work out yeah so I'm gonna have to make
that my variable okay let's call it now
so therefore on the basis of this go
back to your equations for X dot and Y
dot X dot is V cos alpha right by the
way if you have to remember which ones
which is just like on the unit circle
right so it goes alphabetically X goes
with C for close and Y goes with s
cosine because it's in okay I know what
V is and I don't know what my angle is
so I just gotta leave it like that okay
in the same way I can get my vertical
velocity so that's gonna be 200 so okay
so far so good
so let's use this and bring it over here
next equals c1 so when T equals zero
okay I know what the velocity is equal
to right okay so therefore C 1 when I
substitute this in right I'm gonna get
200 cos alpha because there's nothing
else in the equation right so there's my
X dot it's actually equal to that at
that point so I'm gonna integrate one
more time it's a land on X okay so if in
to get tuned to cos alpha that's just
their constant right so when I integrate
it I should get 200 that lots of times T
right so because that cos functions in
me I'm gonna actually stick the team in
it just looks a little bit so I don't
confuse the alpha and the tape now I
integrate it again so I've got another
constant I really should have said it's
a bit of pain because so many times how
do I work out this constant well again
I've got my initial conditions right
namely that we specified the position of
where it is okay so I'm gonna sub that
in onto my equation so T equals 0 and X
is also equal to 0 right so you can see
your course in this case is gonna be
just 0 everything disappears using your
initial conditions so therefore I now
have my displacement time equation okay
happy with that let's return repeat and
do it for vertical velocity okay so the
acceleration here what's the
acceleration now I was a bit naughty
I didn't say what um I didn't define
gravity as either 10 or 9 point let's go
with 10 that'll make our members need up
so therefore this is where I'm citing
there's my acceleration okay so I
integrate up
yet another constant okay and sure
enough I take my value careful when I
resolve the velocities pop it in and
you're going to get that as your third
constant okay that's just sign up so
substitute that in which will let me
integrate again this summer night into
it because I've actually got something
here ten T turns into yep and because
gravity tends to be either you know ten
or nine point eight you'll see this
minus 5/2 squared a lot more minus 4.9
plus plus my fourth constant constants
coming out of your ears thankfully
because we chose kind of nice numbers
right this constant also will be 0 right
so after you've worked that out
there's your displacement equation for y